in the opening scene the film depicts
the events of the war between China and
Japan in which the Imperial Japanese
Army has invaded Shanghai a team of
Chinese soldiers is sent to defend their
Homeland so they embark on a long
journey towards the battlefield upon
reaching the city of dachshang they find
the place completely destroyed with no
traces of their fallen comrades during
an exploration of the area a scout named
Juan Wu Witnesses Japanese soldiers
burning the bodies of Chinese soldiers
in the distance unfortunately he is
spotted by the enemy prompting them to
give Chase while fleeing the Japanese
Army stumbles upon the rest of the
Chinese soldiers and quickly attacks
them fortunately Duan Wu manages to grab
his younger brother xiaohubei and his
uncle before hiding inside a collapsed
building as night falls the surviving
soldiers as well as the deserters
quietly escaped the war zone They join a
machine gun company that guides them to
a hideout in Shanghai which appears to
be the last stronghold against the
Japanese Army at first the commander Zhu
Zhang refuses to work with the deserters
and decides to eliminate them however
Lieutenant Colonel XI jinuwon recognizes
the need for a larger force in the war
and assigns the deserters to fortify the
area outside in the midst of their tasks
Tuan Wu approaches Colonel XI and
clarifies that they are not deserters
explaining that their squad was attacked
however the colonel doesn't listen to
him and sends him away later that night
while the deserters are working they
notice a group of refugees seeking
shelter they enter the international
settlement which is under British
control Tuan Wu's Uncle attempts to join
the crowd secretly in hopes that he'll
be safe there however he is turned away
due to his military attire as soldiers
are not permitted entry back at The
Hideout the soldiers are captivated by
the enchanting voice of a woman singing
from a building across the river this
serves as a poignant reminder that even
during desperate times music always
prevails and so do boobs meanwhile the
younger brother Hubei becomes friends
with a boy named Kiyu who is of similar
age in another part of The Hideout the
deserters in the basement stumble upon a
hidden passage leading to a stable
housing a white horse one of the
deserters releases the horse causing it
to gallop uncontrollably within The
Hideout fortunately Kiyu manages to calm
the horse by whistling
now come on now girl in the British
concession area the streets are filled
with refugees seeking safety a professor
named Zhang surveys the city through
binoculars and notices that the Japanese
have occupied another building in
Shanghai he also observes the Japanese
soldiers advancing towards the last
remaining Shanghai Hideout a few moments
later they reached the place and
discovered that only a few deserters are
present leading them to believe that the
Chinese soldiers have fled however this
proves to be a trap as the Chinese
soldiers who were hiding inside swiftly
launch a surprise attack a fierce battle
ensues and several Japanese soldiers are
killed on the spot there are casualties
on the Chinese side as well but only a
few one of them is duanu's Uncle
eventually the enemies are overpowered
and defeated due to the Superior Tactics
of the Chinese in the aftermath
Commander Zhu orders the deserters to
scavenge and loot the bodies of the
deceased Japanese soldiers shortly after
the deserters are ordered to eliminate
the remaining Japanese survivors within
The Hideout old Abacus one of the
deserters is armed with a gun and
instructed to go first he is initially
hesitant but Commander Zhu forces him to
pull the trigger at gun points after
this it is Juan Wu's turn but he becomes
visibly shaken Zhu forces him in front
of the captive Soldier and urges him to
shoot when dwan Wu still hesitates
Colonel she reminds him that they had
killed his uncle driven by Revenge Duan
Wu finally takes down the soldier
meanwhile a Chinese journalist named
Fang goes to the Japanese base and meets
with Colonel Kono isao to whom he sells
valuable information about the Chinese
Hideout upon receiving this information
Colonel Kono immediately initiates plans
for a new attack later the Japanese
soldiers positioned outside the Chinese
Hideout attempt to get the attention of
the Chinese soldiers within they demand
surrender threatening to execute their
captive team members if they don't
comply however the Chinese soldiers
instead opened fire in their Direction
in retaliation the Japanese Army hurled
several gas bombs forcing the Chinese
soldiers to seek Shelter One generous
Soldier provides Duan Wu with a face
mask saving his life amidst the ensuing
chaos Duan Wu accidentally falls into an
underground Canal where he discovers a
secret Escape Route Outside The Hideout
the leakage of the harmful gas from The
Hideout engulfs the surrounding area
triggering Panic among the in the
settlement they frantically Flee for
their lives later that night three
Chinese students attempted to sneak from
the British concession area to the other
side as they want to fight they make
their escape through the gate but sadly
they are apprehended by British soldiers
meanwhile some people from the
international press on the second floor
of a nearby building capture footage of
the Shanghai Hideout at The Hideout Duan
Wu makes an honest plea to his superiors
explaining that he and his brother are
mere farmers and should be allowed to
leave unfortunately he is once again
ignored determined to explore potential
Escape Routes swanwoo then returns to
the underground Canal during his
exploration he is spotted by old Abacus
and another deserter who joins him in
his quest as they move ahead they
surprisingly spot a group of Japanese
soldiers stealthily entering The Hideout
through the same Canal trapped with no
immediate means of escape the trio
submerges themselves underwater
unfortunately one of them cannot hold
his breath for long and he passes away
once the Japanese soldiers pass Tuan Wu
and old Abacus Kosh emerge but are
spotted by civilians who promptly make
noise alerting the British army thinking
quickly Duan Wu claims that they're not
attempting to escape but instead came
out to alert everyone the Japanese
soldiers have infiltrated the area this
causes chaos prompting the Chinese
soldiers to quickly awaken and defend
themselves they managed to successfully
repel the Japanese soldiers and retain
their Hideout following these events
Juan Wu and old Abacus are reprimanded
by Colonel XI who seems to suspect their
true intentions as a result of this they
are assigned a punishment and sent to
reinforce the Frontline defenses
meanwhile the three students who
previously failed to enter The Hideout
make a second attempt and managed to
gain entry this time the next day
journalist Fang engages in conversation
with high-ranking British officials
disclosing that Japan intends to seize
the last remaining hideout in three
hours Fang gets paid in exchange for the
news and the officials ask how much he
would like to bet on it however Fang
doesn't seem to be interested in it so
he simply walks away after a few hours
the Japanese soldiers launched their
attack on The Hideout prompting the
Chinese soldiers to make a valiant stand
in defense of their territory desperate
to bolster their forces the Chinese
soldiers distribute weapons to the
deserters and even the students
compelling them to join the fight
against the Japanese true then a Fierce
and deadly battle erupts between the two
sides resulting in the loss of numerous
lives in a strategic move the Japanese
soldiers use a crane to demolish a
section of the building's wall
responding to this the Chinese soldiers
adapt by employing gas tanks instead of
conventional grenades as the battle
escalates the three students who were
initially eager to participate in the
war now become scared and desperately
search for a place to hide tragically
one student dies when a grenade
detonates nearby and another is shot and
injured as all this is happening Hubei
peeks through the window and catches a
glimpse of the Majestic White Horse
Galloping by this gives him a moment of
happiness and so he innocently tells his
friend Kiyu to do the same unfortunately
as soon as Kiyu peeks through the window
he is shot in the head and killed the
old look at the horse prank gets him
every time on the other side the
Japanese soldiers construct Shields and
attempt to breach the building's wall
alerted to this plan a Chinese Soldier
reports it to his Superior the soldier
then wraps himself in explosives and
leaps off the building killing several
of the enemies although he passes away
himself he gives his men a solid chance
to defend their territory inspired by
this act of Bravery more Chinese
soldiers follow suit sacrificing their
lives to preserve their land soon the
nearby civilians also decide to
volunteer their help disguised under a
Nazi flag they attempt to deliver a
telephone wire to The Hideout however
their progress is hindered by a Japanese
sniper positioned at a distance who
cruelly fires at them despite the danger
a group of determined civilians forms a
line willing to risk their lives to
transport the cable roll across among
them is a staff member of a casino who
manages to cross the bridge despite
facing a barrage of gunshots upon
reaching the end of the bridge he hurls
the cable towards the Chinese soldiers
but gets killed in the process with this
sacrifice the Chinese soldiers inside
The Hideout are able to establish
communication with the city afterwards a
group of journalists including Fang
successfully enter The Hideout to gather
in information regarding the situation
among them a journalist named Jiang Jing
documents The Soldier's heroic defense
of The Hideout for a remarkable three
days she interviews Colonel XI inquiring
about the remaining number of soldiers
inside The Hideout to motivate the
Chinese people and to let the world know
that they are strong the colonel
deliberately inflates the figure stating
800 instead of the actual count of 420
420 would have been a lot cooler
meanwhile old Abacus ceases an
opportunity to steal Feng's coat
intending to escape from The Hideout
however he is apprehended by Juan will
when he is held at gunpoint old Abacus
pleads for his release confessing his
fear of death and his longing to see his
wife moved by his desperate pleas dwan
Wu is overcome with compassion and
ultimately allows old Abacus to go free
calculated outside the civilians start a
donation program to provide support for
the soldiers inside The Hideout
collected supplies are slung towards the
soldiers through the building's Windows
the owner of the casino donates a flag
and a young girl named men bravely swims
across the river to personally deliver
it witnessing her courageous act Juan Wu
assists her in entering through the
window however a bullet grazes to one
Woo's neck inflicting a minor injury
during the same night Colonel XI
announces that the generalissimo has
ordered them to defend The Hideout for
an additional two days aiming to Garner
Global attention this means that they
shouldn't raise the donated flag as
doing so would provoke the enemy and
invite a more ferocious attack however
this doesn't sit well with the soldiers
as they claim that they are fighting for
their motherland not to impress others
so they decide to raise the flag and
show the enemies that they're still
fighting the following morning all the
Chinese soldiers gather on a rooftop and
the flag is slowly hoisted as Colonel
she delivers an inspiring speech the
soldiers are met with cheers from the
civilians however soon after the
Japanese dispatch a fighter jet that
begins firing at the Chinese soldiers
resulting in a devastating loss of life
despite the onslaught the soldiers
valiantly fight to keep the flag from
falling at one crucial moment Duan Wu
takes aim at the enemy pilot but
narrowly misses after 10 minutes of
continuous Onslaught the Japanese forces
finally retreat in the aftermath we
learned that Juan Wu has been shot in
his abdomen in his final moments he
requests Colonel XI to take a photograph
of him for his brother Hubei the
following morning Colonel Kono arrives
on a black horse to hold her discussion
prompting Colonel she to mount the White
Horse and meet him recognizing that the
Chinese will soon receive orders to
retreat Colonel Kono suggests engaging
in an honorable battle between them
before he is replaced emphasizing that
it will be their final fight Colonel she
agrees and returns to prepare his
soldiers for the impending Showdown
later that day the commissioner arrives
at The Hideout and issues an order to
surrender the last standing stronghold
to the British Colonel she adamantly
refuses but the commissioner argues that
with no external assistance and a
seemingly lost cause it is inevitable
convinced by the commissioner's
reasoning Colonel XI reluctantly agrees
to prioritize the lives of the remaining
soul soldiers and they begin
preparations for retreat in order to
provide a diversion and buy time for the
others to escape a group of soldiers
including Hubei selflessly decide to
remain behind and distract the Japanese
forces as night falls the searchlights
are turned off to facilitate the
Soldier's Retreat then the Chinese
soldiers are instructed to form groups
of 20 and cross the bridge increasing
their chances of survival meanwhile a
crowd of civilians gathers on the
opposite side observing The Soldier's
perilous crossing the situation
intensifies as the Japanese activate
their own searchlights and unleash
Flames to make it easier to Target the
soldiers on the bridge despite the
daunting circumstances the Chinese
soldiers bravely begin their Crossing
while the Japanese opened fire this
causes several Chinese soldiers to get
shot one after another witnessing the
tragic scene unfold the civilians on the
other side decide to assist the Chinese
soldiers they prepare medicine and even
Engage The Enemy from their balconies
firing shots in support tragically the
majority of the Chinese soldiers are
killed on the bridge Colonel XI also
sustaining a gunshot wound remains on
the side of the bridge overwhelmed with
grief as he realizes he cannot save
everyone the movie concludes with
civilians extending their hands from
behind a barricades helplessly
witnessing the merciless shooting of the
soldiers